- [Mark] All right, Luna.
- Hi.
- [Mark] Hi.
Luna, tell me about your life.
Where'd you grow up?
- [Luna] California, but everywhere.
- [Mark] So you're a California girl?
- Yeah, Cali girl.
- [Mark] And you grew
up with both parents?
- No.
- [Mark] Who'd you grow up with?
- Well, so I grew up with
my mom and my stepdad
from one years old until six.
And then I got taken
away into foster care.
- [Mark] Really?
At what age?
- Six years old.
- [Mark] What happened?
- I was being abused and molested.
- [Mark] By who?
- My mom and my stepdad.
Yeah, my mom was hitting
me and stuff and all that.
- [Mark] And then your
stepdad was molesting you?
- And my sister.
- [Mark] And your sister too?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So they lost both of you?
- Mm-hmm.
And then my older brother too.
- [Mark] Wow.
It must've been bad.
- Yeah, it was pretty bad.
But that's okay.
- [Mark] And did you end up
with another family after that?
- I ended up with a lot of families.
I was moving like every six months
and then
I was being touched and stuff
at my foster homes and stuff.
And then
I went back home for about a year
and then I got taken away again
a month before my 13th birthday,
because I went to church one day
and my pastor's wife saw
a whole bunch of bruises all over my body
and called the cops.
And then the cops came.
- [Mark] And the bruises were from who?
- My mom, she had just
beat me the day before.
So, yeah.
- [Mark] Wow, that's a rough childhood.
- Yeah, I had a pretty rough childhood.
My mom broke my jaw when
I was four years old.
- [Mark] Jesus!
- Never took me to the hospital,
never really worried about her kids,
just about drugs.
- [Mark] Your mom was doing drugs?
- Yeah, my mom was big druggy,
but she's doing better now.
- [Mark] And so you
have your biological mom
and then you have other families that
took care of you as well later on?
- So I have my biological mother
but she lost parental rights over me.
I just started talking to
my real mom when I turned 18
because I had ran away
from foster care at 16
because I was being hit and
abused and moved all the time.
And so,
I got put into a group home
because I hit a certain age where,
in foster care,
when you hit a certain age and
you've been in it for so long
and you haven't had a steady home,
they're gonna put you in a
group home because then you're
a "bad child"
even though you're not a bad kid.
So, basically I was being starved
and my foster parents were
locking the fridge and stuff
and wouldn't feed us.
And I would tell my social worker
and she wouldn't believe me.
So, I ended up leaving.
- [Mark] Wow.
And what age were you
when you finally went out on your own?
- 16.
- [Mark] 16?
Did you finish high school?
You didn't.
And what kind of kid were you back then?
Were you a troublemaker or not really?
You were a good kid?
- I was never a bad kid,
I was a really good kid.
I think because I went
through so much and...
Trying to find a family that you fit in.
I can't. I'm gonna cry.
- [Mark] It's okay.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And then where'd
your life go after that?
- Pretty good.
I'm sorry (sobs).
- [Mark] No, no, no, it's all okay.
Everybody does.
- It's a lot of stuff, it's
like flashing back in my head.
- [Mark] Just look at
it as a therapy session.
- I didn't really like my therapist.
(Luna laughs)
- [Mark] And so at 16, 17,
18, you're on your own.
And what were you doing?
- So I had moved in with
my boyfriend and stuff
but
he was basically a drug addict and stuff.
And so then he,
introduced drugs to me and stuff.
And so I tried 'em, but I didn't like 'em.
I didn't like the way it made me feel
or the thoughts that they
put in my head or anything.
So like, I didn't do it
anymore, but he still did.
So then he became
very abusive and stuff.
So basically I was just
living that kind of life
for a long time.
- [Mark] And what kind
of jobs were you doing?
- I wasn't really doing any jobs.
I was basically just trying to stay hidden
so I wouldn't get put
back into foster care
because I knew I wasn't gonna be better
off in foster care
because I was just gonna
keep going to the same stuff.
- [Mark] So you were kind of hanging out?
- Yeah, and nobody was
gonna care about me.
I was just another kid that
whose parents didn't want her.
- [Mark] Yeah.
And then what happened after that?
- So basically after that,
when I turned
18 I found out I was pregnant
and I had my first kid, which is my world.
He's my best friend.
And then after I had him though,
I started going back to school
and then I had to quit school
because I had to focus more on him.
And basically I didn't finish school
but I only have like five
credits left in math to do
so I'm almost there.
But,
and then I ended up getting
into the porn industry.
- [Mark] How'd you first
get introduced to that?
- So,
weirdly odd to say I
was going on Craigslist,
looking for modeling jobs,
and I ended up finding a talent scout
or whatever.
And
he said that I was really pretty
and I could do the modeling and
everything, but it was porn.
So like I had talked to
basically my husband about it and stuff.
And
he's very open.
My husband, he's very open with me.
I try to explain to him about
my feelings and my intentions
and everything.
So he's very understanding
and he knows what I've been through.
So,
he doesn't try to,
put a weight too much on me.
He tries to, instead of the
bombard me with questions
and making me feel some type of way,
he just tries to listen.
- [Mark] That's great.
That's unusual.
- Yeah.
He's really good. He's my rock.
So like, basically I went
onto my first shoot (laughs)
but I was a fluffer,
so I had like the lube.
And like I was there like,
"Hey.
(Luna laughs)
"I can do basically."
And
I fell in love with it because of
how open everybody was
with their body and how,
like the guys made the
girls feel comfortable
and the girls made the
guys feel comfortable
and everybody's smiling and laughing.
It was just like having fun
but it's taking photos and other things.
(Luna laughs)
So basically I fell in
love with it at that moment
and I knew I wanted to do it,
but I still had that dream in my heart
of wanting to be a model.
So,
yeah (laughs).
- [Mark] Yeah.
And I know that you can
really do both very well
at the same time.
- Maybe.
(Luna laughs)
- [Mark] Maybe you'll be the first.
- You know, just (mumbles)
- [Mark] And eventually you
got into being an actress
and being on camera?
- Yep. And then I...
As soon as I did that
then I talked with some agencies and stuff
and then I met my agent
and he seemed very nice.
And like, for a first time,
he was very like on the dot of
like what should be going on
and what should happen
and stuff and everything.
So I felt very comfortable.
- [Mark] You make good money doing it?
- So, when I was doing it, I
was making real good money.
So I was making bank.
And then like, I took a break for a while
because I had a lot of
stuff going on and stuff.
So I needed to basically re-cleanse myself
and get everything right and everything.
So, I'm just now getting back into that.
I've been back into it
for about two months now.
And I'm good.
- [Mark] You're good.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Are you involved
in drugs or alcohol,
anything like that?
- I smoke marijuana.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's like aspirin now.
- That is a plant.
(Luna laughs)
No, I don't really drink
if I drink, I like whiskey.
I'm a whiskey girl.
I don't really like any kind of drug.
I mean, I want to try 'shrooms
'cause I heard it's a really
good psychedelic trip (laughs).
But that's about it.
- [Mark] So what is one
of your favorite things
about being a porn actress?
What are the upsides and downsides?
- So, the upside about being
a porn actress honestly,
is like, I kind of have a high sex drive.
I love
what makes people click.
I like to know like the
different kinds of turn ons.
I don't know.
Like, I'm that person that like
I want to find out what turns you on
because that's gonna turn me on.
So there's so many different
kinds of people in the industry
that I never knew about.
And it intrigues me.
I don't know how else to say it
but it really does intrigue me.
The downfalls about porn.
Sometimes you get weirdos.
(Luna laughs)
- [Mark] Yeah, true.
I mean, do you go to the grocery store
and all of a sudden
somebody recognizes you?
- Yeah, sometimes those
are just weirdos or like,
people that just want to
write weird stuff to you
on your Instagrams and stuff.
And it's just like,
and then they start cussing
you out because like,
you don't want to look at their dick pic.
(Luna laughs)
So I don't...
But there's not really too many downfalls.
I mean, we get tested every month
and if you don't come
out with a clean test,
so you don't work.
- [Mark] You don't work?
- So that's one thing I also,
had that security blanket when I work,
'cause I know I'm gonna be safe,
I know I'm gonna be taken care of,
and I know I'm not gonna be disrespected.
Because at any point in
time that I feel that way,
the shoot stops,
and I get paid still.
So I never have to feel like,
something bad's gonna happen.
- [Mark] So, a lot of
protections in place?
- Correct. There's a lot
of protection in place
for the girls.
But at the same time,
it's all about agency.
Who's your agent?
Because there are some
agencies out there that,
are not good agencies.
And a lot of girls are open to communicate
with other models and stuff
and let them know their
personal opinions on stuff.
So, inside of,
agencies is really good.
So getting to know other models
and other actresses in the
field definitely does help
instead of going at it blindly,
definitely do research.
- [Mark] Does being a...
Doing what you do for
work affect your marriage?
- No.
- [Mark] Your personal life?
- No, I mean--
- [Mark] I mean, being romantic
with your husband must be...
I mean,
what you did this afternoon
is probably kind of...
It's hard for me to wrap
my head around doing that.
She did that all day,
and now we're sitting
on this sofa together.
- No. It doesn't bother him.
For him,
like I said, there's so
many different things
that people are turned on to.
My husband actually is turned
on to watching me have sex
and stuff.
So, he actually gets turned on by that.
So at that point I'm like, "Okay.
(Luna laughs)
"Hey."
- [Mark] You found the right guy though?
- Yeah.
Like I said, he accepts me.
He thinks I'm beautiful
even when I'm sitting there
throwing up and pooping myself.
(Luna laughs)
- [Mark] He loves you.
- So he accepts me.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Well, Luna, thank
you so much for talking to me.
- No pro... Sorry about crying.
- [Mark] No, no, no.
- I had to stop myself.
I was like, "Nope."
- [Mark] You're okay, we're all human.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You went through
stuff. It was hard.
- I did. I'm sorry I didn't
open up a little bit more.
- [Mark] What else was
there to talk about?
- I don't know, lots...
(Luna laughs)
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] We can still...
I can edit it together if
you want to go further.
- No, that's a lot.
(Mark mumbles)
That's why I started crying,
'cause it's like, it all just started...
- [Mark] What did I miss?
- I don't know.
Like so I have PTSD
'cause of a lot of stuff
that happened to me.
And so sometimes it's very hard for me to,
express
what I'm feeling inside,
or say what's going on in
my head because I shut down.
I don't mean to, it's just...
I think when you've been
hurt so much in life,
you have a wall.
- [Mark] I mean, I'm going to pry
so I'm telling you right upfront.
I mean, you were molested
and that's certainly as
traumatic as you can imagine.
What else was there there
was (mumbles) PTSD closet?
- Molested, abused,
being abandoned,
not only by my mom and dad,
but by my sister.
Because when we went back into
foster care she said that,
she didn't want to take
care of me anymore.
And that she was taking
care of me my whole life.
So I ended up being in
foster care all by myself.
- [Mark] All by yourself?
And you have an older sister?
- And I was all by myself
moving all the time
while my brother and sister were just...
They just got lucky.
- [Mark] Wow.
- Life sucks.
And then you die.
- [Mark] Yeah, but your
attitude seems really great.
- You know, I can't...
- [Mark] Like I wouldn't
even detect anything
like what you told me when I'm with you.
'Cause you seem so light on your feet
and easy to smile.
- The thing is that I've come
to conclusion within my life
is that, I can't change
anything that happened to me.
And I can't go back in the past and
I can't dwell on it
for the rest of my life
or else I'm not gonna go anywhere.
So, the only thing I can do is embrace it,
have it empower me
and push me forward to not be
somebody I don't want to be.
- [Mark] Figuring out
ways to let go of anger
is the key to being happy.
- Honestly, it's the key.
It's not saying that you ever forget,
because it's things you will never forget
but it's forgiving
for me, for the inside of me so I can,
move on with my life
instead of having people
have power over me.
That's how I can talk to my mom.
That's how I can talk to
my family and everything
it's because I don't let them
have the power of they hurt me
and I've proved to them
wrong every single day
that I'm still pushing forward
and I'm still becoming
the person I want to be
even though I came from nothing
and I had no help from anybody,
I still fucking did it.
And I'm proud of myself.
- [Mark] You should be.
(Luna mumbles)
(Mark and Luna laugh)
Thank you so much for that.
- No problem.